hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back a monster on our world
again and today we're gonna be ranking
the top 5 hardest monsters and monster
on a world to hunt like the V if you do
enjoy subscribe if you're new I cover
the solo guides for most of the monsters
and monster on a world which most of
these monsters in this list I have solo
guides for event quests for every week
in tips and tricks for everyone to
become a better monster on her player
and with that let's get started so as I
said we're gonna be talking about the
hardest monsters and monster on our
world to hunt but to judge these
monsters we're gonna be going over how
tough the monster is how complex their
moveset is in terms of how many moves it
has does it do elemental damage are they
difficult to dodge or defend as well as
how the surrounding area you might
usually fight them in is we're really
quick though just to get this out of the
way these are all my opinion you can of
course disagree with this if you think
something should be changed in the
top-five list let me know this will only
be 4 monsters in Monster Hunter world
and we'll be going off the fact that
these are untempered and just normal
monsters and I am aware that most of
these monsters have been in previous
games but I've only played monster on it
world and that will be the only thing
that we're talking about and how they
function in Monster on the world and
then lastly of course obvious spoilers
ahead since we will be mostly mentioning
the endgame monsters but with that let's
actually get started number 5 to start
us off as COO shala de aura cushaw while
still being difficult the fight ends up
at number 5 because if you have flash
pause this fight is an absolute joke
there was a recent flash pods nerf but
that only goes to tempered monsters so
this basically has no effect flash pods
of course were in the vision of the
monster will stun them along them t4u to
get some free hits and if the monster
was flying it's basically a KO and then
they follow and spaz on the floor since
the flash partner is not taken into
account you can do this tons of times
and the fight will be over super quick
one thing that also helps is that all
the areas except one are very open areas
the only one being his nest so when he
does this tornado attack you can easily
move to another area of the map without
being trapped in which kind of makes
this move a little bit redundant of
course he is in elder dragon so his
attacks are powerful but with the amount
of pillars in the area you fight him in
you won't be hit very much by these
number 4 on our list is Zeno Jeeva as
you know Jeeva is the last monster you
fight in the main story of monster on
our world so you know once again is a
decently hard fight except there's a few
things that make him easy one is his
ginormous hitbox he is one of the
biggest monsters in this game and while
still hard-hitting he is very slow on
attacks most of the time I was hit
because I was accidentally got stuck in
a animation locker that be from the dual
blades full swing or anything else like
that another fault also is how big his
area is although I will give him some
credit he does have some long-range
moves if you get too far from him which
can do a lot of damage if you're not
careful as you know does have the
ability to cause fire damage if you walk
on the lava on the floor that he makes
but rolling a couple times and you'll
get rid of that super easily and as well
his moveset is a little bit complicated
at first with the amount of variations
and this move said depending on what
face he is or not but after a few tries
it's almost like second nature number
three on the list is Kieran Kieran is
definitely a tough fight but not as
tough as the others higher up on this
list his Thunder damage is absolutely
insane and can do incredible damage if
you don't get rid of the Thunder blight
which is also very threatening sometimes
even wearing the Thunder provement it
will barely save you from this move is
about his ability to also prance around
and do more than just knock-back damage
and the fact that if he hits you too
many times you could be stunned which
will most likely lead you to open
powerful attacks is also the reason he
is on number three but his moveset isn't
too complicated but very high damaging
one move for instance is this lightning
chain attack words anything is lit up
blue will be electrocuted making you
think whether to charge him or to get
and get some free hits or wait till he
powers up and sit back and wait and play
a passive but the area is a little bit
forgiving in the amount of cover you get
when fighting him in some areas as well
as the surplus of Melbury surrounding
the area if you didn't bring your knee
or ran out during the fight making this
a little bit easier you can also use the
wedge beetle scattering the higher parts
of the Coral Highlands to either lure
him to a better area to fight or mount
him and knock him out number two on our
list is T Ostra the fireline as I like
to call him is a very difficult opponent
to fight his most weakest point is in
the head but that also wears most of his
attacks come from so it can be very
challenging to hit him without getting
hit yourself especially because of his
fast speed he can pounce her on the map
by either closing the gap between you or
spreading out to do a ranged attack he
has the ability to do fire damage with
most of his attacks as well as blasts
which could turn the tables on the fight
if hit while having the blast play on
his most deadly move being the super
nova fire explosion which can one-hit
most hunters if not careful he was
definitely one of my most difficult
fights and monster on her world just
because of the previous statements I
just mentioned and on top of that most
of the areas around him are in lava
pools so cool drinks are very much
needed throughout this fight
next up is the number one pick but
before we do that I'm gonna run through
two honorable mentions really quick
which is the simplified reason why as to
not take too much of your time up and
the first honorable mention is going to
be fall hazaki out of the three you
fight in the quest with tio Shoku shala
involve Bal personally to me has to be
the weakest one of the bunch there's way
more than enough room to escape
effluvium gas as was if you're hit there
is no berry surrounding the area to get
rid of the status effect his moveset is
also very simple once he fight him he's
the only elder dragon out of the three I
have managed to beat without failing the
quest which is why he got the honorable
mention next and the final honorable
mention is Oda Garen I will give Oregon
the credit he deserves though he is very
fast and more on more of a dual blade
user so keeping up with his fast speed
was no problem I can definitely see the
difficulty for using something like a
hunting horn or a hammer but for me he
was no problem his boot attack is very
deadly which gives him that edge in the
fight except most of the time after he
hits you it'll basically just focus on
your palico shortly after allowing you
to crouch and gain your health back
while also getting rid of the bleed
effect which kind of made the move
redundant half the time but now and
lastly to end the video we have the
number one spot and that goes to Naga
ghonte or spiky boy you have to play
like Nagant aid to defeat him which is
why I love this monster so much fast
quick attacks and high mobility just
like him
he has such a devastating move set which
can kill most hunters easily with one
shot or two if you don't do enough
damage his spikes can cause them to turn
solid black and all of it and all of
your attacks will bounce off of it this
can then lead him into going into his
dive-bomb one-hit kill if you're not
careful the easiest way to prevent him
is just to play like him rush him deal
as much damage as possible and as quick
as you can to make sure those spikes do
not grow back basically nothing in the
surrounding area will help you in the
fight except to tiny ledges to mount him
and a couple flash pods in his nest but
that is a rare chance that he will
actually break that part open and not
the place where he sleeps so it is just
up to chance that he will break that
there is some vitality plants in the
crystal room but when he is constantly
putting pressure on you it can become
very hard to get those plants to get
those extra health luckily though after
a while his moves that can be very
predictable just like all the monsters
in this game but I thought he personally
deserved to be the top spot on this list
but that guy is gonna be into the video
tell me your thoughts in the comments
below what your top 5 list would be
whether you thought you agreed with mine
disagreed with mine will you change
something or anything like that I'd love
to
in the comments describe if we knew I
cover solo guides for most of the
monsters in Monster Hunter world which
most of these monsters in the list I
have solo guides for event quest for
every week and tip is in tricks for
everyone to become a monster hunter
player my most recent video will be on
screen as well as a playlist for the
solo guides for the harder monsters in
Monster Hunter world so if you need help
defeating some of the monsters in this
list definitely check that out and with
that guys hope every wrister day and
peace out thank you for watching the
video